uh so it's time for our program
and our our our speaker
he currently serves as a member of
president trump's economic recovery task
force
he's on a leave of absence from the
heritage foundation
where he is a distinguished visiting
fellow and works on the project for
economic growth
he was for many years a regular
columnist and a member of the editorial
board at the wall street journal
he's the founder and former and a former
president of the club for growth
and he also founded the free enterprise
fund
as i'm going through his bio i think you
can see a theme emerging
with him he previously served as a
senior economist for the congressional
joint economic committee as a senior
economics fellow at the cato
institute and as a senior economics
analyst at cnn and we we won't hold that
last one
uh against you
during the 2016 presidential campaign he
served as a senior economic advisor to
then candidate donald trump
and help draft the trump tax plan he's
the co-author with art laffer
who some of you have surely heard of art
laffer of a book titled trumponomics
inside the inside the america first plan
to get our economy
back on track he's spoken for us a
number of times over the years
including at this event the free market
forum and we're delighted he's able to
be with us again
steve moore
hi everyone uh thank you so much for
having me i'm i'm such a
huge huge fan of hillsdale college and
uh
it is just um at least we have one
school
in america that teaches um free markets
and so
uh it is just uh really a thrill for me
to uh
to uh to be um here with you all tonight
i think one of the most things i've ever
um
that i've written in my life the most
read thing
and i'm not exaggerating was like eight
years ago i had a piece an imprintature
and i don't know i was like two million
people read it so i love that
publication and congratulations on that
um i want to talk a little bit tonight
about uh
about what is going on with our
political system and our
in this amazing election and kind of tie
it back to economics and
let me start by saying that i was
privileged in 2016 to
uh work for donald j trump and um i
didn't i tell the story in our book
about trumponomics that when i first
uh when trump first called larry kudlow
by the way how cool is it larry kudlow
is the most important economist in the
country today i mean larry's just such a
superstar
and he's my best friend and he was my
best man in my wedding so
we worked side by side we got the call
from trump to go see him this was
about you know about five years ago i
went to trump tower and
and and uh and met trump and and i
always i tell the story in my book at
the time i had a very negative
impression of donald trump i didn't
i didn't like his persona i thought he
was kind of an egomaniac
sometimes he still is but you know i i
thought you know he's this is a
publicity stunt that he's running for
president
anyway we went in and we met with trump
for a good hour
and i was just dazzled by the guy uh how
many of you met donald trump in person
i think a lot of you have i mean he's
just an amazing he has that uh
x factor that just you know lights up a
rum and you know i've always said
there's uh
you know three prior people i've met in
politics that have that
you know incredible um ability to
connect with the american people
uh ronald reagan of course uh bill
clinton and barack obama
and you know as is great i always say
that as great a um
uh a politician um as
as ronald reagan was that even he
couldn't handle
uh hold a candle to bill clinton because
bill clinton could literally and
figuratively charm your pants off
but um but um you know but trump does
have that
you know he's amazingly charming and
he's he's he's someone that i've come to
really
um respect and and admire and he has
turned out to be as president wouldn't
you agree much more conservative
than i even thought he would be you know
he's been amazing he's
he has i mean he really has he's one of
the
rare things about think about this with
donald trump
one of the rare things about him is he
has done
exactly what he said he would do right
what
wow what what when i was at you're right
i for as penance for serving for donald
trump
i had to go to cnn for two years you
know and that was you know that was
brutal
uh and it was the hate trump network and
uh
anyway you know i would be on it would
be six against one and they just
beat up on trump relentlessly and you
know every time he would do something
you know like pull out of the
uh you know the paris climate accord
which by the way is that one of the
great things that donald trump did is
pull america out of the anti-america
uh paris climate accord these these
liberals would come up to me the
puzzle and they go why is donald trump
doing this
and i said because he said he was going
to do it right i mean he does what he
said he's going to do
and so uh anyway he he's been amazing i
think he's been a a great president
with respect to what he's done for our
economy and uh
i i want one of the messages i want to
leave you with you tonight
is this is a totally competitive race
i've lived this through this before four
years ago exactly this time
every single political pundit every
single pollster in america
said that donald trump has a five to ten
percent chance of winning remember that
a five to ten percent chance of winning
um and uh and so they were wrong wrong
wrong
uh and we're going to see that again i
think this is a total
um jump ball race right now i really do
i think it'd go go any either way
in the next four weeks and we have to
work work hard
uh if you're somebody for trump we have
to work hard to make sure that
um he does win but i've told this story
before i think i told at the last
hillsdale event i was at but i think
it's
it's really indicative of why you cannot
trust these polls they're just
completely untrustworthy
and i i was in florida about two weeks
before the election
uh in 2016 and i was not feeling great
about things at that time because that
remember that
bush that tape had come come out about
trump where he said some lewd things
about women and i thought gee this is
the
this is the end for trump and we had
been making all this progress and then
this tape comes out and i thought oh my
gosh we can't overcome this and i
remember i was feeling really low and
and i was walking down the street and i
saw a bumper sticker on a car
and sometimes in life a bumper sticker
can tell you more about what's going on
society than any 600 you know
a word essay or a 600 page book and what
this bumper sticker said i'll never
forget it it said
vote for donald trump nobody has to know
and i thought wow that's that's that's
the answer that's why i won
and what i'm here to tell you about is
there are millions there are millions of
what i call undercover trump voters out
there we all know them
they're people who would never tell a
pollster that they were going to vote
for donald trump they would never tell
their friends they're going to go for
donald trump we know we know that from
2016.
and what these voters did was they went
into the voters booth they may even told
posters they were going to vote for
hillary clinton
and they pulled the lever for trump and
i think that's going to happen again and
so
um so i i'm i'm feeling pretty confident
now
what i wanted to talk a little bit about
um
tonight is is what we've gone through in
the last nine months and what lessons
we've learned
this is uh this is a seminar about free
market economics so
what have we learned about in terms of
the governmental interventions in the
face of this pandemic
so i'll just start with the headline of
what i have to say and i think you're
going to hear more of this tomorrow i
think you have an amazing panel
on on the pandemic but my kind of
headline is very simple
i believe i wonder how many of you uh
agree with me on this
that the lockdown of the american
economy was one of the greatest mistakes
the united states have ever made
and it's not even close this has been um
it has had catastrophically negative
consequences
not just for the economy which are
pretty obvious but also the health of
the american people
and i would argue that it's not even
close that the costs of these lockdowns
have been orders of magnitude
larger than the um than any benefits and
so
we realized right from the start that
that uh this was going to that that
government was going to
seize power in unprecedented ways when
this
pandemic uh hit these shores back in
march of 2020 when we started to really
see
some people get um cases of of corona
and so on and it was pretty clear
that that there had to be somebody
pushing back on this
and so we uh we started a group with uh
with people like art laffer and
a bunch of great economists like steve
forbes and others to try to push back on
this and say let's
let's be rational by the way this was
even before we knew
what we've learned over the last nine
months one of my frustrations is
we're still doing stupid things nine
months later
i mean did you see new york today
actually imposed more lockdowns
more lockdowns on their economy so there
hasn't been a learning curve
but our line from the very start is that
we have to keep the economy open
because you can't have a society without
a functioning economy
but we have to do it in a safe and
secure uh
way and so we started looking at what
the governors were doing and by the way
i think
i think trump's narrative and even mike
pence by the way it wasn't mike pence
incredibly marvelous last night he just
did an amazing job but i i think that
the rep
that trump and pence don't have the
narrative right about what's going on
with respect to coronavirus trump did
something
that we all as people who believe in our
constitution and federalism
um and sound economics really
um support and the left does not support
this which is one of the first decisions
we
told trump would be very wise thing to
do is look we're 50 states
let the states deal with this nebraska
by the way this is a great great state
the great state of nebraska
is not new york right nebraska doesn't
have to have the same
kinds of uh you know health codes that
that
new york city does i mean it's just
stupid and by the way that's why this
idea
of the left that joe biden keeps talking
about about we have to have all these
national policies that's just wrong
we need to let states determine how to
handle this
and we did and i think that was one of
the smartest things trump did
and as a consequence what we saw i don't
want to get too
far ahead of myself but what we've seen
very clearly
is that for the most part not entirely
republican governors have handled this
in in a very very effective way
and democratic governors have have
handled it in an incredibly
ineffective way uh and so the first
thing we did
was we we put out a report card about
how the governors were doing
in terms of handling the crisis uh in a
way that would keep their economies
rolling
would not just flatten their businesses
and their workers but it would also keep
their
their uh you know their their people
safe from from this terrible deadly
disease and by the way i have two good
friends
uh who've died from coronavirus so i'm
not minimizing
the lethality of this terrible terrible
uh pandemic
but what we saw is that the states
almost immediately got adopted
completely opposite strategies
in terms of dealing with the crisis and
so you can see the red states
actually you know the red and kind of
brown states those are the states
that that put in in place very very
strict and severe lockdowns
and you can see it was the you know
obviously these are these are the
democratic states california
uh oregon washington and then you can
see the northeast is is all all
you know uh very very uh red in terms of
red meaning stop
stopping economic activity and then you
can see the green states
the the ones in the middle and the ones
in the south those are states that did
not have
overly bearing overly bearing
restrictions on economic activity okay
so that's point number one
let me show you the next chart so we
then we go these are the grades of the
governors
and by the way i know how many people
here are from colorado i know that
there are some people that i know i met
three or four people you've got a pretty
good governor in fact
uh not every your governor jared polis
was the one
democratic governor that we gave an a to
he was he was not especially restrictive
and and i'd say to this day that that
jared polis
has done a very fine job in terms of
dealing with this crisis
in colorado but then you see all the
other states are basically um republican
states
how many floridians are here any
floridians i see one or two
ron desantis has emerged as one of the
great superstars and and
i mean ron desantis has just been
amazing uh and he's
he's he's done an incredible job dealing
with the crisis and then you know the
georgia government of 13 georgians in
the room and the iowa governor has been
at nebraska your governor here in
nebraska has been outstanding
and oklahoma has had a great governor
south dakota i think you had did you say
you had an event with
christine oam who's another rising
superstar
she's done amazing job tennessee wyoming
these are the states that did the best
work
um you know work and then you see the
ones at the bottom uh these are states
like uh virginia where i live and states
like um
well you know it's basically the ones
you would expect illinois
new york new jersey connecticut uh and
so on
did an abysmal job they basically just
flattened all their businesses and
destroyed their
their cities by the way if you have any
of you been to it's it's
tragic because i'm i'm one who loves
american cities
i mean i just think you know our gems
are the great great cities of america
i'm from chicago i think chicago is one
of the great world-class
cities in the world and it is
so saddening to me how inept
liberal leadership has destroyed these
cities you know
they've been hit twice now they've been
hit with the coronavirus
and then they got hit with these riots
and incompetent leadership that
that allowed rioters and criminals to
burn down their
immigrant businesses and and the people
who've been suffering the most from that
by the way are the lowest income people
it's really disgraceful what's happened
by the way anybody here from new jersey
i'm sorry
i mean new jersey has the worst um
governor in america in murphy and he's
been
catastrophic and and so now you let's
look at the
actual record of what happened so these
are uh a little bit of out of date but
not out of date but not much these are
the death rates
of the major states uh you know so let's
just look at how they did
did they how did they handle the crisis
and this is deaths per 100 000 people
and you can see here that look at where
the deaths are
new york new jersey um and by the way i
don't have massachusetts on here but
massachusetts had a very very high death
rate rhode island had a very very high
death rate
illinois had a pretty high death rate
connecticut had a
high death rate uh these are states that
had the strictest lockdown
and yet they had the they had the most
deaths
so look i'm not a health expert i don't
i don't have any
expertise in health whatsoever but i am
an economist i can look at data
and when you look at this you say wait a
minute the states that have the
strictest lockdowns
also had the highest death rates then
you look at the states like arizona
georgia florida now by the way these
death rates have gone up a bit
uh in those states because the virus you
know in in the late summer went through
these states it's basically through
florida now it's through georgia it's
through arizona so their death rates are
now
you know in the 50s or so so it's not
quite as imbalanced as it was but
the fact is that these states did not
lock down they did have a wave of
coronavirus go through
but they were not devastated like these
like these
blue states were so then the next
question is
what have we done in response to
coronavirus
what has been the the federal response
and this is something
as a one who believes in limited
government and and free enterprise
is very disturbing to me we have
massively spent money
on these programs and it has been highly
high
questionable about how effective these
things have been so we've had four or
five rounds of
federal spending they call these um the
you know these
stimulus bills and by the way i think
everyone in this room
knows something that almost nobody in
washington seems to understand
government spending doesn't stimulate
anything
right government spending does not
stimulate anything except government
uh and this is the pro all you're doing
is taking money from one person and
taking giving it to another
it's not like there's some kind of magic
money in washington that that
is uh that is uh you know adding to the
gdp
and so what we've done is we've already
spent about 2.3 trillion dollars
that's a lot of money by the way 2.3
trillion dollars
think about that i mean i had a piece in
the wall street journal some of you were
saw and were mentioning it and i just
did a thought experiment i said
because right now as we speak there's
negotiations between the white house
and nancy pelosi about another round of
stimulus you know that's been held up
for the last couple of months
and pelosi wants two well originally she
wanted 3.2 trillion dollars
now she wants 2.2 trillion dollars and
the white house is at 1.5 trillion and i
think
at some point they may you know make a
deal i hope they don't
we don't need another stimulus bill it's
not going to help the economy
but here's something to think about for
2.2 trillion dollars
we could completely eliminate the
personal and corporate income tax for an
entire year
that means no business no american
worker out of 150 million
workers would have to pay any income tax
for a year
now this isn't too complicated isn't it
is it i mean what would be better for
the american economy for the federal
government to collect two trillion
dollars
and then go out and spend it on all
these giveaways bailouts the
the transit systems and bailouts to the
airlines and bailouts of this thing and
money for the arts and money for the
blue states and all this stuff or
would it be better for the economy to
just cancel think of what the account
the economy would explode in 2021
if there was no income tax on american
businesses or workers i mean it would
explode it'd be the
biggest stimulus in the history of
civilization and instead of that they
want to spend money and even a lot of
the republicans want to do that
so that gives you a sense of how foolish
this is
government spending is not going to get
us out of this crisis there's only one
thing that can get the economy
moving and that is to get the states to
open up their economies it's that
simple if you've got businesses that are
flattened and you've got people that
can't go back
go to work because the government won't
allow them to do it
and if you've got governments shutting
down stores and restaurants and churches
and all of these things
it doesn't matter how much government
money you put into the system it is not
going to rescue the economy so
i've been like one voice and there's
many many many who keep saying over and
over again
just if you want to get the economy
healthy there is no substitute
for uh for um you know for
opening up the businesses and allowing
them to uh to grow
now this just gives you a sense of the
foolishness of what we've done this year
this is showing total government
spending uh this year we start
with you know every year state and local
governments spend about two trillion
dollars
then we added 1.5 trillion dollars to
the first couple of rounds of stimulus
now pelosi wants another three trillion
dollars now she's saying two but
originally she wanted three
then we started the year with 4.7
trillion dollars of government spending
even before
coronavirus hit you add all that up
we're talking about 10 to 11 trillion
dollars of government spending
the only people who've benefited from
the only sector of the economy
that has benefited from this coronavirus
has been government that's the only
sector that's been growing
and what is wrong with that picture now
let me show you the next one this
shows you gdp this this should frighten
everyone in this room
i showed this very chart to the
president by the way two weeks ago i was
in the oval office with the president
and i showed him this and he was aghast
at this i mean if we were to
now this we were talking about when she
was talking about uh three trillion
but even even if it's two trillion
dollars we're going to for the first
time in american history
have total government spending over 50
percent of our gdp
america the land of the free 50
even at the height of world war ii when
we're fighting the nazis in the japanese
government spending only rose to a high
of about 45 percent of gdp at the height
of world war ii
throughout our history you know gov
federal total government spending has
been about 15 or 20 percent of gdp
we're going to go to 51 i mean
that's beyond bernie sanders wildest
dreams right and he's a devout socialist
so
you know i say mr president we can't
allow that to happen on your watch do
not
allow another massive government
spending and that that just shows you
the chart you know look what just
straight up in terms of government
spending
in 2020 especially if we allow that that
next bill to go through and here's just
showing the components of government i
mean government would be the biggest
industry in america it would be bigger
than
you know private investment and it just
shows you all the other components
of our economy they dwarf uh in
comparisons with uh with government
um same thing with uh here's another
thing look at this is the change in
employment in the united states
virtually every industry obviously has
lost
jobs right i mean and you can see
obviously the leisure industry has
gotten
really hammered but almost every
industry has lost jobs there's a few
exceptions the technology sector has
done well
but the one major sector that has not
laid off people is the government
the government is hiring more and more
people while the private sector is
laying off people
which is uh which is why one of the
things i strongly object to
and i pray when i say my prayers at
night and pray that donald trump does
not make a deal with pelosi
the reason that this whole stimulus bill
has been held up right now
is nancy pelosi wants 500 billion
dollars
for blue states for blue states for
illinois
for california for new york new jersey
connecticut rhode island massachusetts
and
that is not something that we can accept
why
why should people in states like texas
and tennessee
and utah and idaho and nebraska
and and states like georgia and south
carolina have to pay more taxes to bail
out the blue states
the blue states have acted incompetently
and one of the points i made to the
president when i saw him two weeks ago i
said mr president there's a term in
psychology called
enabling enabling if we bail out the
blue states what we're doing is enabling
them to keep their government their
private sector shut down we're enabling
cuomo to make the stupid decisions he's
making week after week
it's less likely that cuomo is going to
open up his economy
if we give them money not more likely so
i i urged him not to do that we'll see
what
what what happens that's kind of the
same thing
um this just shows you that uh you know
the the big layoffs have been in the
private sector
if you were you're basically twice as
likely to have
been laid off if you're a private sector
worker than a government worker
um that's not fair uh and then i want to
just make a couple of other points
so if you if you look at the
unemployment rates
of the states because i just did a
document a documentary for
prageru how many of you watch pregeru
videos those are fantastic and i had a
great time working with those folks
and dennis prager produces those you go
out to california and if you haven't
seen it yet
it's only been up for like two days and
already has 2.5 million views so it's
gone viral
and it's basically blue state versus red
state america and this is something this
has been one of my themes i'm writing a
book about this now that america
we are two countries right now you know
the first line of my thing is
we are not right now the united states
of america we are not
we are not united we're just not i wish
we were but we're not
we are we are a divided states of
america today
you have red state america that is doing
one thing and blue state america that's
gone way over the left
and there's not a lot of in between
right now and so you have true
two completely different models in play
right now uh
red states have lower taxes low red
states have less regulation
red states have uh are are states that
uh have uh
uh um right to work laws they don't
compel people to join a unit
we're all in favor of union i don't have
a problem with unions i don't have a
problem with private sector unions i do
have a problem with the government
compelling people to join a union
and so uh you have you see a big divide
between what the red states are doing in
the blue states and
uh it makes a big difference the blue
states are melting down right now that's
the big story of america this is what i
want trump to say
america doesn't have a coronavirus
crisis right now the blue states do
america doesn't have an unemployment
rate story problem right now
you know you have 12 red states today
including nebraska
and iowa and utah and georgia and a lot
of these other states that have
unemployment rates of less than six
percent
even having gone through a nine-month
crisis with coronavirus these states
have basically close to full employment
you've got 10 states right now that have
unemployment rates over 10 percent
and guess what nine out of the ten are
blue states
run by democratic governors and that
tells you a lot
not only did they kill more of their own
people but they also put
you know uh flat in their economies and
and that's a i think a really important
message
now when i show this to my some of my
liberal friends i say look you look at
one of my favorite things to do is just
compare the four biggest states in the
united states
right the four biggest states are texas
florida
new york and uh and uh california right
and as
this is a kind of perfect experiment
because two of those states are are very
red states
uh florida and texas and two of them are
very blue states
new york and california and so then you
look at the results and you say okay
what's happening in those states well
guess what over the last 10 years
1 million people have have moved into
florida
i'm not that is one million more people
moved into florida that moved out of
florida
and 1.2 million more people moved into
texas than moved out of texas
meanwhile you look at these blue states
new york
lost 1.3
million people in 10 years on that 1.3
million people
california by the way how the hell do
you screw up california
right i mean it's it's like paradise and
i mean it's beautiful mountains
beautiful beaches
beautiful weather beautiful women i mean
what's not to like about california
for the first time in american history
there's an outflow of people from
california did you know that
people are leaving california they lost
a million people on that
the 2020 after the 2020 census for the
first time in american history
california may actually lose a
congressional seat
that's what's happening people are
leaving yeah that's a good thing right
people are leaving these and by the way
i actually don't say that i mean i love
california
by the way i did do you all know who
paul krugman is by the way he writes uh
you know for the new york times he's
probably one of the most influential
economists in the country certainly on
the left i mean
what he says is bible to them and i did
a debate with krugman
about um two years ago on the subject of
red state blue state
and i said look paul you got to explain
this to me all these blue states like
new york and connecticut new jersey and
in california they do in illinois but
illinois is a separate you know case i
mean it's just
does anybody here from illinois any
illinois i mean it is
i'm sorry i mean illinois is just a
disaster right now and i i love illinois
but the
incompetent leadership has really done
so much damage but i said
krugman i said look paul you have to
explain this to me i know you know i
know i have a small brain compared to
yours and i know you've got a
nobel prize but you know i said i don't
understand something
you know you keep saying it's a great
thing if we raise taxes
if we by the way do you all know what is
the income tax rate in florida today
zero there is no income tax in florida
what is the income tax rate in texas
zero how in the world is uh
is joe biden going to create seven
million jobs by raising every single tax
rate in the united states
i mean really how how is that at all
possible he's going to
raise taxes by four trillion dollars and
create five million jobs
how how is he going to do that i mean
clearly
you know when you look at the states tax
rates have a big you know big
influence so anyway i asked krugman
how's this what explains this
migration out of these northeastern
states to the to the
southern states and krugman said well
steve you do have a pin sized brain you
just don't understand this
he said people are moving out of the
blue states the red states because of
the weather
because of the weather and you know i i
didn't really like to have to do this
but i i hit him pretty hard and it was
below the belt but i said
i got up and i said well you know uh you
know professor krugman and you are a
very smart guy and
you know i'm not nearly as smart as you
are and i kind of scratch my head and i
just i just don't really understand
something i mean i said
if all of this migration is due to the
weather
why are people backing up packing up
their bags and leaving san diego for
houston
and of course he didn't have much of a
much of a response to that nobody leaves
san diego for the weather right
and so anyway this is an important point
that we have to make over and over again
their model has already been tried we've
tried the joe biden model
and you look at new york city and you
look at chicago and you look at the ruin
of these states and we can't
uh allow that to happen uh this is just
showing you know
you know economics is so simple it's
economics is all about incentives that's
really
all it is all about that's what outdoor
laughter teaches us if you
tax something you get less of it right
if you tax something less you get more
of it this isn't complicated why do we
tax people for smoking because we want
people to smoke less
uh and so uh so the the proposals out
here
are to um we we had a proposal to uh
to suspend the payroll tax we just said
okay you want to help middle class
people
just stop paying you know let's stop
paying the payroll tax for six months
and trump loved the idea
and they wouldn't do that they would not
uh suspend the payroll tax
what the democrats wanted to do was
extend unemployment benefits now this is
a classic example of stupidity in
economics that becomes policy
so nancy pelosi insisted in that
bill that passed that heroes act back in
um
back we passed that back i think in may
for 600
a week bonus unemployment benefits to
unemployed workers 600
a week now most of you probably know
this because it's been written up
quite extensively that it's 600 a week
by the way not 600
a week benefits 600 a week benefits on
top of the normal benefits that people
got
and so it turns out that for about 75
percent of workers
we were actually paying them more money
to stay unemployed than to go back on
the job
now that's pretty dumb right i mean
that's a pretty stupid thing to do
and so as the economy opened up guess
what
it was the bizarrest thing we had 30
million unemployed people
but we had seven million job openings
people wouldn't go back on the jobs
why why wouldn't they go back to jobs
because they were being paid not to go
back on the job by the way as soon as we
cut those benefits guess what people
actually did go back on the job
and and that is you know showing you
that that the
negative effect of these unemployment
benefits would be sort of catastrophic
so
i'm going to i'd actually like to take
some questions from you
all i i think this is going to be a very
tight election
i think trump is is going to win because
of the undercover voters that are not
being counted in these polls
i think it is highly consequential
election i think this
is um this is a total conflict of
visions
between left and right and one of the
things and i'll just sort of stop by
saying this
one of the things that really bothers me
is this idea that somehow
look let me put it differently this is
not a contest between
donald trump and joe biden this is a
contest between donald trump
and the hardcore left in america and
they will
if they take over it will be in my
opinion catastrophic for our country we
cannot allow this to happen
and by the way it's one way of thinking
about this this is a race
between donald trump and the media right
this is the media have you ever seen
anything like this before
in your life the treatment of this
president
i mean it is it is so
disastrous uh and so unfair the way this
president has been treated i mean don't
you agree with that i mean it's just a
disgrace
and so uh and trump just plows through
it
uh and he will win and i think you know
if we if he wins and i think he will
i do think we're going to see the
greatest economy ever i'll just leave
you with a couple statistics
we had a census bureau report i'm very
proud of this because i helped put the
tax plan together that that biden wants
to
repeal we put that tax plan together
we put together the uh the deregulation
efforts trump basically let
the oil and gas you know industry boom
by the way
did you know for the first time in 60
years under donald trump
the united states for the first time in
most of our lifetimes
is now producing more oil and gas than
we're consuming
we are a net exporter of oil and gas
we're the number one producer of oil gas
in the world today
so those are amazing amazing
accomplishments
and i'm sick and tired of the media
saying oh well the only people who
benefit from donald trump's policies
are the rich right that was what kamil
o'hara said last night
only the rich benefited from donald
trump's policies that's nonsense
so let me give you some of these
statistics the census bureau just came
out with the
census bureau is the gold standard of
economic data for the united states
and what they found was that for 2019 so
this was right before the corona crisis
because their data is delayed about six
months
they found that um in 2019
the poverty rate in the united states of
america
fell to its lowest level ever in the
history of the united states
i mean think about that i mean and not
only that but it fell
to its lowest level for blacks hispanics
asians women lgbtq i mean any group you
want to talk about
that rate fell to an all-time low
that's incredible the lowest rate of
poverty ever here's another one
median household income i'm not talking
about bill gates i'm not talking about
warren buffett
i'm not talking about warren buf you
know lebron james i'm talking about the
average middle-class family in the
united states
their incomes in three years went up six
thousand four hundred dollars that's
huge under barack obama in eight years
median income only went up two thousand
dollars so think about that
in in three years under the pro
free market policies of trump middle
incomes went up
three times faster than they did under
barack obama in eight years
and i would submit by the way you would
think the fact that we had the all-time
high in incomes and the all-time low
and poverty rates wouldn't you think
that would be like a blazing headline in
every newspaper in america
i mean that's a pretty pretty exciting
stuff right
that we've made we've you know reduced
poverty we've had
huge increases in income i couldn't find
it in any of the newspapers
and i would submit to you to you if that
had happened
under barack obama it would have been a
headline like you've never seen before
right i mean that gives you a sense of
what we're up against in terms of the
media
finally just to yeah and one other point
we are now how many of you watched the
debate last night how many of you
watched that and most of you did
i mean the the these moderators are just
driving me crazy right i mean the
moderators have been
so skewed against trump and they keep
asking these loaded questions that are
like left-wing talking points
so one of the points that susan uh
what's her name susan paige made
yesterday
was she said uh vice president pence you
know the economy's slowing down and
you know we're it's not it's not working
anymore blah blah blah
it's like what the hell is she talking
about we have created
11 million jobs in five months
11 million jobs in five months the
unemployment rate has fallen to 7.9
every single economic projection uh by
the congressional budget office the
federal reserve bank every independent
economist at one wall street
said that we are out of 12 or 13
unemployment now that's what they said
six months ago we're down to eight
percent
that's incredible having gone through
this incredible pandemic
uh we have seen here's here's one other
statistic
which is what i call the october
surprise because this number isn't going
to officially come out
for another week or two but it is coming
out and i may be wrong by a couple of
percentage points
but i track this stuff very carefully so
the gdp
for the third quarter which just ended
on september 30th are you all sitting
down
so this is an amazing number the gdp for
the third
quarter of the united states of america
will be up 32
32 that by the way
the old record usually like a three or
four percent
increase in gdp in over a quarter is a
really good number 33
we've never seen anything like that in
the history this economy is not slowing
down it is coming back big time
the only thing that can prevent it from
coming back and i wonder i'm not a
conspiratorialist
but i wonder if these blue states are
keeping their economy shut down
precisely so that the numbers don't look
good for trump maybe i'm just a
conspiratorialist
but anyway um thank god we have people
um
you know great great institutions like
hillsdale college you guys do an amazing
job teaching our
kids and uh and i just wish every child
in america could go to hillsdale
thank you very much it's been a great
great pleasure um i'd be happy to
if we have some time i'm happy to take a
a few questions i'd love to hear kind of
what's
on your mind do we have a few minutes
sir yes thank you mr moore we now have
some time for q a okay
please raise your hand and we'll bring a
microphone to you
okay hi hi good evening my name is
carlson
and i was just wondering if you could
make a comment about
our relationship with china under the
trump administration and how it would
look different
if we had a vice president biden so this
is a really important question
um because i'm being fully
serious with you um who do you think are
the
who do you think benefits the most in
the whole world
who will benefit the most of joe biden
as president well i'll name
three people who benefit vladimir putin
president xi in china and the saudi uh
oil sheiks they will benefit greatly if
if biden becomes president um they are
rooting for him and
in fact you see a lot of chinese money
you know they talked about russian money
coming in
you know for trump what's happening
right now chinese money is stay
delusion into the united states behind
biden do you think
china beij do you think president xi
wants to deal with another four years
with trump
hell no he doesn't this is a president
and by the way when i first met trump i
disagreed with him on china
you know i don't always agree with one
of the things i admire about trump is
you can disagree with the guy he loves
to argue actually
and he makes he's a great executive he
makes the decision we we slug it out a
lot of times he likes that
uh but you know i said you know donald
i'm a free trade guy and blah blah
and he's actually changed my opinion i'm
still for free trade i'm a milton
friedman guy
but you can't have free trade with the
country's predatory they have predatory
trade practices
what's happening in china right now is
extraordinarily dangerous
it's ex this is china in my opinion is
is japan circa 1939 that's how dangerous
the situation is with china they're
building up their military
they are i'd hate to be hong kong or
taiwan right now they're
they've already marched into and taking
land out of
from india this is a scary situation and
trump is to his great great credit is
the first president who said
china is not a friend they are not an
ally
they are an adversary and an enemy how
many of you agree with that they are not
a friendly power today
and i just shudder to think you know and
and you know you know this i mean when
it comes to china
joe biden is a patsy he's a patsy and
so it's a great point i thought i would
never say this
and i'm not trying to scare people in
this room but but you can tell i feel
passionately about this election
i i do believe that if joe biden is
elected president in these left-wing
policies like four trillion dollar tax
increases
and dismantling our uh you know our
energy industries
and i mean look folks we have a 20
trillion dollar economy
is there anybody in their right mind who
thinks we can power a 20 trillion dollar
economy that produces cars and steel and
technology and
food and all this stuff you can do that
with windmills i mean how stupid is that
really it's it's the stupidest and by
the way you know mike pence was right
last night
does that do you all know what country
in the world has reduced its carbon
emissions more than any other country
we have we have we're not the villain
china is
you want to talk about the country
they're they're building a hundred coal
plants as we
speak every time we shut down a coal
plant in the united states
china builds 10 of them how is that
reducing carbon emissions so
it's a great point and i think that we
that's another reason why
why trump needs to win i think sir you
had a question
dave begley from omaha i want to thank
you steve for an exceptional talk this
evening
my question is could you give us a
little more color or insight
with regard to your private meeting with
the president two weeks ago
well i'll tell you coming to find some
fun stories about donald trump because
he
first of all donald trump is truly a
freak of nature
i mean the guy does not sleep i'm
serious i mean he is the hardest working
person i've ever met in my life
i mean some of you may know him
personally i mean
every time i mean when i was working on
the campaign with them four years ago
it'd be like two o'clock in the morning
the phone is and you know my wife would
ask the phone and
she ran over to me and i say you know
she said uh steve it's donald trump what
are you doing i'm like what am i doing
it's two o'clock in the morning what do
you think i'm doing i mean the guy just
goes and goes and goes and goes and goes
and you know he's amazing um he's
he's an amazingly good person it's just
personally he has been so good to me
really i mean he is he's a great friend
to have if you're
in a fight you want donald trump on your
side you really do he is he's an
amazingly loyal person to people who are
loyal to him
um but you know there's just so many fun
stories about him by the way you know
one of the
i talked about this in the book when i
first started working for him
and i traveled with him which was a lot
of fun during the you know 2016 campaign
and we'd go like three or four cities in
the day in a dizzying schedule
and it was just exhausting but anyway
you'd never have you go from one event
to another to another another
and you wouldn't have time to eat right
because you just run into the place you
do the
event and then you run back and get on
the plane and fly somewhere else so you
know the
the only time you had to eat was when
you're on the plane and so i thought
this could be so cool
you know uh when you when i uh when when
i
first traveled i said this would be
great the guy's a billionaire it's gonna
be
caviar and lobster and champagne you
know and
and we get on the pla and every event we
did every lunch and dinner were exactly
the same
it was mcdonald's big macs for lunch and
domino's pizza for dinner this is a man
of the working class right and
it's just really very very uh funny um
but you know one of my favorite stories
about trump because i just was with him
um i'm not going to tell you some of the
things he says behind closed doors but
i was at a dinner with him about about a
month or so ago
and it was with actually it was with a
bunch of the governors the republican
governors had been
in in town and uh it was so he was
giving a talk to like there were about
30 people in the room so it was a very
casual thing and he but he was standing
in a podium and he was just kind of
having a fun time and
and he saw that the governor who was
right in front of him like you know
you're right in front of me
he was kind of sipping his wine and so
trump just said off
he said um hey governor he said do you
know i don't drink
by the way how many of you knew that
about donald trump that didn't try i
didn't actually have been around him and
never occurred to me that i had never
seen him drink
so he said to the governor he said
governor do you know i don't drink and
the governor kind of nodded his head and
said yes mr president i've heard that
about you
trump's kind of policy goes governor can
you imagine me if i drank
that that's a very funny thing he has a
really self-effacing
sense of humor by the way i wish you'd
use that right i think one thing that is
missing from these debates
is humor reagan used humor so
effectively
uh but you know my other that same night
by the way it was
he had a there was a pastor who was
there who said this opening prayer for
the dinner
and then he took some questions for
people and the pastor asked him this
question
and he said you know mr president he
said you know when you
sin do you get down on your knees at
night and ask the lord for forgiveness
and i thought that's an interesting
question to ask donald trump and so
um trump like literally was like
standing there for a minute like
thinking about it like
most people said of course i asked for
forgiveness but trump
trump thought him for it for a minute
there's this awkward silence and he goes
he goes you know i just can't think of
anything that i'd have to ask the lord
for forgiveness for
so he's very he can he has a great sense
of humor and uh
he's a hard worker and he works for us
you know that's the thing about him
i mean that's the other thing this is
not a hard choice guys right
we have guys who've been in politics for
45 years and done nothing with his life
and you've got a guy who's an
accomplished businessman right
who's done an incredible job as
president have there been mistakes with
corona virus there have yeah he's made
mistakes
i think biden would have even made
bigger mistakes but you know how in the
the one reason there's another reason i
think trump is going to win
is if you look at the polling there's
one you know
there's one question that really stands
out to me and it's i think the reason
trump is going to win
and that's this question who do you
think can handle
get the economy up and running again
that number trump is when it's just
creaming by because people do understand
trump does know what he's doing when it
comes to the economy and biden doesn't
have any idea what he's doing
so i think in the end of the day a lot
of those undecided voters say because
look
trump's big problem is this 56 of voters
do not like donald trump
they do not like him so he's got to
convince
about 10 of these people who don't like
him to vote for him anyway which they
did in 2016. i guess there's
one over there
we're going to take a question over here
really quick oh sure where are you
oh there you are sorry hi hi steve thank
you so much for tonight i am i'm
unfortunately from california but i'm a
cpa so i i just have a really quick
comment about the debate and the tax
stuff last night followed up by a
question
when they were talking about the tax
savings last night i actually pulled
data from my program
and compared found about 300 comparable
entries
and what i found was uh families and
individuals
who made approximately on average six
thousand dollars more
from 2017 to 2018 and paid about 1200
less tax than yeah and so it's real you
know these are just
clients from my system but my question
would be
um i think one of the actual worst parts
about donald trump's tax plan
is the salt deduction and specifically
that it
is equal for single and married couples
so it's a huge
um marriage penalty um so i just wanted
to hear your comments on that and if
there was anything that you would change
from the tax plan
as it stands right now well first of all
i i hate to tell you this but i was the
single biggest proponent in the white
house
for i was insistent upon this that we
include
that we get rid of the state and local
tax deduction now i know that some of
you may live in blue states
but all the state and local you know i
remember i mentioned the word
um enabling all the state and local uh
tax deduction do is enable states like
new york and illinois
and new jersey and california to have
high taxes and why should people
in texas have to pay more federal taxes
to subsidize the fat
flabby government services in california
it just is it isn't fair
and and by the way the reason is so
interesting this is an amazing thing
that
nobody in the press wants to focus on
there is a tax cut
in in um in uh nancy pelosi's plan
there is a tax cut you know what it is
she wants to bring
we what we did is we limited it to ten
thousand dollars you could you could
deduct your state and local taxes up to
uh ten thousand dollars and for ninety
percent of
american tax filers you know they
they don't go above the ten thousand
dollar level so it only affects
the top you know ten percent and the
vast fast
60 of the benefits of getting rid of the
state and local tax deduction
go to the top one percent and guess
what two states those people live in new
york and california
and so it's in so that's the one tax cut
that pelosi has in her plan and the
irony is it would be the single biggest
tax cut for rich people in the history
of the united states what would i have
done differently
i'm a steve forbes guy let's just have a
flat tax of 18
and get rid of all the deductions and
make it as simple as possible right
i mean wouldn't that be the best
solution to our taxes get the rates down
low
and this is what's really disturbing to
me you know
uh to me the essence of good tax
tax policy is the principle of having a
broad base
and low rates right you want you want
taxes not to be
distortionary about uh decisions and by
the way
in 1986 and which wasn't that so long
ago you had like people like bill
bradley and dick gephardt and ted
kennedy
and everybody agreed low rates broad
base what what the
biden plan is exactly the opposite what
biden plan does is
raise the rates and he's including all
of these new loopholes
for people who run so you know solar
energy firms and people who have
windmills and people do this and that
and the other thing
and that's social policy through the tax
system so i'm
i'm a flat how many do you like the flat
tax raise your hand i mean come on
that's what we need all right i got i
think we have time
i'm running out of gas maybe one or one
or two more quick ones and then
we'll let you guys go hi i'm
rich from colorado we have traveled over
the midwest and last several weeks and
see
all kinds of trump support in the rural
america
and we're very appreciative of that
however
my concern is the
ballot harvesting and all the other
shenanigans that we have seen
that may occur and probably will occur
and it's a matter in my opinion that
after the november third election the
democrats will say
how many votes do we need to take over
and they will do whatever is necessary
to make it happen what's your concern
uh well i have exactly the same concern
i mean i i believe that if this is a
fairly held election donald trump will
win
but we saw this in 2018 sir you know we
saw especially in california
you know i think the republicans lost
six congressional seats
after the election when they said oh
here's another bag of ballots we didn't
oh where did these come from
you know and and they just keep counting
ballots until they they
uh declared a bunch of their
congressional candidates winners so
i'm very very worried about that and i'm
not i'm not an expert about
you know ballot fraud but i think it is
it is uh the mail-in
balloting is going to be a big problem
but your point about you know what's so
interesting about america because i'm
traveling a lot um
you know throughout the country and you
fly into the cities
and you see about the biden signs and
then it's almost like a linear
relationship
the further away you get from the cities
it's trump trump trump trump trump trump
trump
and uh you know that that's a really
interesting phenomenon
i mean i i when i four years ago when i
was in ohio
i did an event about three weeks before
the election for the campaign
and it was about 45 minutes out of out
of
toledo and we're driving towards indiana
and uh i'm looking out the window
because it's very ohio actually is a
pretty rural state it has a lot of
beautiful charming little towns
and and uh and i'm looking out the
window truly just like you said sir all
i saw was trump trump trump trump
trump i mean people would have these
barons with these gigantic trump signs
on him and stuff
and i i called corey lewandowski the
campaign manager said corey this is
amazing
i'm looking i'm i'm here in ohio i know
this is a battle state
and i said all i'm seeing is trump signs
and it's literally
as soon as the words were out of my
mouth we go around a corner
and sure enough there's one of those big
blue hillary signs so
i said oh you know corey never mind i
just saw a hillary sign and my driver
says to me joey says
hey steve take a closer look at that
sign we get a little closer it said
hillary for prison
so but you know there is a there is a
real relationship between
you know the divide is between urban and
rural maybe one more and then we'll call
it a night if there is any more
um hi sir hi peter jacobson from the
courtney institute uh thank you for
taking my question
about two decades ago you published a
book it's getting better all the time
with the late julian simon
i'm curious your take today if the theme
of optimism that's in that book if you
have that optimism today
and is that optimism contingent on this
election or is it more robust than that
thank you wow that's a tough question
you know that that's i've because i've
been thinking a lot about that and
you know i was really proud of that book
we were talking at dinner how many of
you know who julian simon was
raise your hand julian simon was the
great one he was my mentor
uh this is an important i'm going to
take a minute to answer this because
it's an important point you made and
then we'll break this up
julian simon took on for those of you
don't know who he was he was a doom
slayer
so remember in the 60s and 70s it was
all uh the world is overpopulated we're
running out of oil we're running out of
gas we're running out of food we're
you know the world's becoming more
polluted you know all
that was the first of the climate change
craziness and so on and
julian simon was the one scholar of
among thousands among thousands who said
no
this is all wrong we're not running out
of food we're not running out of oil
we're not running out of gas we're not
you know the environment is getting
better not worse in every way
and truly people thought he was a
lunatic
i mean they wanted to they said he
should they should take his phd away
from him he doesn't know what he's
talking about he's taking on all the
established scientists who are saying
just the opposite
well guess what it was julian simon who
was completely vindicated
in everything he said i mean nobody
today believes we're running out of oil
and gas right
nobody believes we're running out of
food nobody believes that the world is
overpopulated
none of those things actually happen and
the reason
i wanted you all to think about this is
that
you know if this if he were alive today
they would shut him up the left would
shut him up and shut him down
they would muzzle him they have this is
a frightening thing what they're saying
about science today
they have so politicized science when
the left says we have science on our
side
what they mean is we find five
scientists over here who agree with what
we say
and so that's the science and it's
happening you know it's even happened in
the in
in how they're dealing with this disease
now they're actually asking the doctors
are you republican or a democrat
and so on and so i find that to be very
this isn't science
when you shut up anyone who has a
different opinion than you do
about these things it's not settled
science none of this stuff is is really
settled
and so uh now your question about
whether i'm still optimistic yeah i am
you know why because i think reagan said
it best i mean america really was
was put here as a beacon of freedom and
what worries me now look if biden
wins it's gonna be bad it's gonna be
really bad i think most people have no
idea how bad it's going to be to let
these leftists
take over the government they're going
to their the deep state will
will be deeply ingrained and and every
dial you know
again economics isn't that complicated
what trump did is he took the dials
and he turned them to pro growth right
we'd reduce the regulations reduce the
taxes we'd reduce
we got government off the back of
business and it was the private sector
it just exploded
so if you turn those dials back in the
other direction what happens
you get the opposite result right i mean
this isn't complicated right
so if you start raising the taxes up
again you're going to get the opposite
result
so it will be a setback for this country
but look we've overcome this kind of
thing
before so i i do think you know i do
think america is going to prevail
the one thing i will say about the last
thing i'll just say is you know my son
who's a millennial
and i'm always railing against the
millennials i just can't stand them
and by the way trump has a big problem
with the millennials it's like 75
percent of millennials are for
abiding i've never seen a gap like this
before you know 75 percent of
millennials are for
abiding and 25 are for trump and so
they've they've
they they're an entitled generation um
and they're snowflakes right and so
i'm always railing against because i
have two sons that are millennials
and i'm always railing against them and
and finally my son got really
just sick of me complaining about his
generation and
he said to me dad just stop he said
who do you think made us this way and
you know
think about it we're to blame we are to
blame we did we're the ones who gave
everybody trophies for just showing up
you know we're the ones who created a
very entitled generation
and uh and so you know we are to blame
we're to blame for the schools
you know who think about somebody like
aoc
aoc is a very smart woman she's very
she's a bright woman
she's very articulate she's bright
where did she come up with these wacky
ideas i mean all she's doing is
regurgitating what she's been taught
since kindergarten
right this is what the public schools
are doing they're indoctrinating our
kids
and if they don't go to hillsdale
college they're being induct-renovated
for another four years in college
we have got to do something about our
education system in america it has to
change
where america will not be america
anymore thanks very much it's great to
be with you
you